first job programming in August of 2000
so I'm getting old anyway I currently
work at school the market still Hands-On
doing programming
and I want to talk about you know our
ideas about what it means to to code you
know what it means you know to do
software and how our perceptions of what
our field actually is is impacting the
software we we create because I think
we're creating a lot of these um
self-fulfilling prophecies you know then
we are kind of using the results of that
to kind of justify why things are the
way they are in the first place so there
are some questions we need to ask and I
want to focus on you know two main
things
and firstly this idea that you know we
keep talking about programming it's like
a natural fit in the science and math
kind of environment and my kids you know
they get you know they get to do a bit
of programming every now and then at
school and it's always in the context of
you know math class you know and all
these like women in stem you know we
need more women in stem it has become
almost synonymous with we you know we
need women in programming or at least
seems that way to me being a programmer
um
and you know that's you know I I fit in
there you know I love I love science I
was good at math at school
um so that's the one thing I want to
address and secondly this comes up more
in like our recruiting efforts now we're
always saying like you know to be a good
programmer you know we want people who
are really who love learning new things
you know like bring it on we love uh
learning new things and this is
essential because our fields
changes so fast you know there's so much
going on if you don't really like or are
capable of learning new things you're
not going to do well
and there's a cause and effect thing
here that I think we need to address
okay anyway so those are the two main
issues I want to talk about and and this
I think we can all agree I think that
this pretty much defines who we are
today we are like the science Geeks who
love a challenge of learning new stuff
this is what we this is Who We Are
but let's be honest like how
how are we going how how is that going I
did a pixabay search for people using
computers and I got this and you know
look at that look how happy they are you
know
look at the Serene smiles and they
didn't like who are we kidding you know
sadly you know this is much more the
reality out there
yeah people more way too often using
software uh does not make people happy
you know we are causing a lot of pain
and suffering actually and this is not
okay I mean at the end of the day the
whole reason we are writing software is
to solve some kind of human need right
at every level actually I mean unless
we're already under the power of some AI
overlords or something like that I mean
it's human needs that are causing us to
write software in the first place and we
are very often failing the humans that
we're meant to be helping and this is
especially true for software that people
have to use a work
so um okay okay but then you say right
right you know it's just a usability
thing we need to get more ux involved
right you know so the users you know
they just don't appreciate good software
when they see it right but us
programmers you know at least we know
how to appreciate you know how to see
the value of the code that we're
producing right
sadly uh as we all know I think this
cartoon by abstruse Goose pretty much
sums up the experience we all feel
whenever we go into a new code base you
know I was like what what is all this
crap you know
why is this structure here you know
where could this bridge possibly lead
this is Bridge you know you know these
comments aren't really helping you know
what is what a horribly designed Street
you know good god what the hell does
this contraption do right and this
pretty much sadly sums up a lot of our
day-to-day experiences of trying to you
know understand the code we have to work
in
and we've all seen variations on this
right this is our you know code quality
metric is uh the number of what the
[__] per minute per in the code review
you know if you just have a couple
that's pretty good you know just a
couple then you're like wow this is uh
this is good stuff if too much okay then
we have a problem
and I'm sorry this is this is not normal
this is not okay you know this is the
other few we mostly we have like four or
five year university degrees that
supposedly have taught us how to do our
job in addition to years and years of
experience and still we are here where
you know every code review there's like
what I have no idea what are you even
trying to do here yeah other fields do
not have this issue yeah I mean there
are Architects you know some Architects
are better than others but you know if
you don't have people going like but
definitely I have no idea what is this
what you know this is not an issue yeah
I mean can you imagine there's like what
what have they done here this is you
know other fields do not have this
problem you know and we all whenever we
see this code they were like oh my God
and we always have these excuses you
know I was like well they guys wrote
this they're idiots you know that's the
problem
or oh but this was written in Visual
Basic you know you know that that's the
problem you know we just need this new
framework or you know a new platform new
library you know or or new language you
know let me just rewrite this and I'll
get it right you'll see
which is why we are perpetually in the
state of making this new platform or the
new solution and we're rewriting
something that the users already hate to
varying degrees uh but we're just
re-implementing it and some new with
some new technology
yeah and all too often we are
totally failing to actually make a
difference where it matters
so again like I've been doing this for
you know 20 years now and you know our
approach it's not working that well you
know this isn't working and it it's not
the tech it's us yeah this technology
stuff
you know it's more or less the same
things that we're Reinventing all the
time you know I'm old enough that I'm
starting to see this myself you know
that the ideas that were true when I
started are starting to come back again
is oh now that's hip again all right
okay you know we keep going around in
circles Reinventing the same things with
slightly different Tech
so I think it's time we ask ourselves
like
are we actually any good at this you
know are we actually any are we good at
making software or more importantly are
we focusing on the right skills
I don't think we are
I think we need to you know go down to
the base like what is programming what
is coding actually all about
and um I'm just trying to think back to
you know how I you know started learning
about programming and I see what my kids
are being exposed to in their in schools
you know and then normally it it boils
down to this you know we're taught like
syntax you know like programming it's
you know we need to learn like
conditionals and you know looping and
you know here's a function here's how
you write a class you know here's how
you use this API you know here's how you
call this thing
here's a variable whatever and
um and this is not really you know this
is important obviously we need to know
these things right this is this is uh
totally at the base this is like
learning the alphabet if you want to be
a writer yeah learning having a
vocabulary that's useful
um but as we can see here I mean this
you don't even have to read the code
here to know that this is absolute
garbage so you can find this and this is
the Gilded Rose refactoring Kata
um
and I mean
this is an absolute mess you know
despite the fact that you know
technically it compiles I mean it
compiles it even works yeah and when it
comes to the programming Basics here uh
I mean they've really nailed the FL
statements you know the the 10 out of
10. look at all those FL statements
they'd really know how to use the basic
programming apis here there's also a
loop in there there's a for Loop uh and
there's a function yeah and that
function is even called in a loop you
know so I mean this is like they've
really got there they really know how to
program you know they're variables in
there and again the performance is okay
or again I mean it could be improved but
it's not the performance that's the
problem with this code that is not the
issue here and most importantly
it's F sharp which we all know is a
modern Superior language that helps us
write better code right see
you know my point is here that
um you know this is this is even though
we've kind of learned a new technology
if you don't know how to write code it
doesn't help to use you know any
language or framework you know and again
none of these basic kind of coding
things are really getting at what it
means to write good code
and sadly code like this I mean maybe
not this bad I mean this is pretty
horrible but I mean there are you know
any number of horrible coding
implementations out there and this leads
reinforces this idea that to be a
programmer you have to be really smart
and you have to be really smart to
understand what the hell is going on
here right you need a massive brain to
be able to understand what on Earth is
happening here you know
um but uh and and sadly we often reward
you know perversely in reward people you
know who are able to work with this
nonsense because there will invariably
be a couple of people in the company who
are able to understand the complexity
and the code right and they're you know
and everyone's like wow he's so smart he
can like you know he gets the task and
he solves it immediately a 10x developer
my God everyone else is like what the
[__] and and he delivers every time
mostly because you know these are the
people who've written the stuff in the
first place right and we really need to
get away from this uh idea where we
reward people for understanding
absolutely incomprehensible complexity
and reward people instead for creating
stuff that's easy to understand that's
where our brain power should go and it
is not today
and you know thinking back to when I
started you know when I went into
programming and I decided this is going
to be my this is going to be my field
this is where I'm going to work
um I thought that I was gonna I thought
that I was gonna be working on I thought
I was going to be working on these
complex same comprehensible coding
algorithms that's what I thought I was
getting into you know code right the
very name it's like it implies that it's
this mystical you know cryptic thing
that only uh select few are smart enough
to understand right you know and I was
going to be one of those people you know
I like that idea I thought that would be
really cool right
um but this is not a healthy kind of
perception of what coding should be
about I remember I did a presentation
for some lawyers a few years back and I
tried to explain to them that you know
code is actually you know English
instructions and you know normal people
should be able to understand it and
they're like no no that can't be
possible you know but I mean if everyone
has this idea the code is this you know
horribly complex stuff then we're more
likely to accept it when we see it this
is not good
and I was reminded again of my initial
kind of you know conceptions of what
programming was all about when I did the
Advent of code challenge last year who
how many people have done the Advent of
code challenge
not nearly enough you all need to do
this now or you know at least in
December it is amazing so it's this
every day in December or until Christmas
you get this little coding Challenge and
just look at the design of the web page
I mean it is fantastic I love the the
you know total basic and even if you
view Source look at that there's hardly
any JavaScript at all it's just like you
know HTML and it is so beautiful and uh
anyway every day you get this um this
little challenge where you typically
have you get this input file that's in
this like cryptic format and you have to
parse the input file and then you have
to do like data traversal algorithms and
stuff to find some kind of results and
then you get Stars if you get it right
and it is it is so much fun but doing
that last year what really struck me was
this is nothing like what I do for my
day-to-day job you know this is nothing
this has nothing to do this has nothing
to do with my day-to-day job this is not
the kind of things I'm not working on
like weird little data traversal
algorithms you know I mean some people
are mind you some people really are you
know but I bet you the vast majority of
the people here that's not what we're
doing you know we might wish we were you
know because it's a lot of fun but
that's not what we do and even at the
algorithm level
um what an algorithm is I mean it's
basically we are what we're doing is we
are writing instructions
we're writing a story there's work that
needs to be done
and we don't want to do it so we get a
computer to do it instead right we are
writing instructions and that is what
algorithms are you know and again unlike
the typical things you get to do at
University or the Advent of code
challenge you know we are writing a [__]
ton of instructions we are writing
hundreds of thousands of lines of
instructions you can't just have them
all in one file you know what I mean I
guess you could like the person who
wrote the you know the refactoring uh
Kata example previously I mean you could
put everything in one file but again
that's not you know what we should be
doing and what we really are doing or
what we should be focusing on is you
know to take all that works that needs
to be done and we need to think about
well what are the you know roles and
responsibilities here you know we need
to categorize the work you know and we
need to assign the work who you know
what entities you know deal with this
thing and how do they communicate you
know which you know which Fields belong
in this data structure how is it
communicated over there it's all about
categorization and organization and
we're you know orchestrating work that
needs to be done and honestly like is
that even a stem field at all
I'm not sure I mean to me this the task
of organization and categorization is
more like a combination of management
and documentation if you look at it
and I think that this is why we care so
much about things like you know agile
and lean and XP and devops and all this
stuff all the processes by which we are
made to work you know because process is
an organization and management that is
actually what we do
that is that is what programming is you
know like my husband's a mechanical
engineer and it's like they don't have
the same interest in processes and stuff
like that you know I think this is this
is actually what we're doing and we
don't even necessarily realize that this
is our fuels
you know we are organizing work we are
managing work uh the only well not the
only but one of the core differences
between you know our type of management
and other type of management is that our
workers they all do exactly what we say
which I guess for some managers out
there might be like oh my God that
sounds amazing
not really not really you know basically
here right merry Christmas on both cakes
and of course that says Merry Christmas
on both cakes they're like no
that's not what I meant
you know if my favorite movie you know
one day you'll add all this will be
yours oh the curtains no not the
curtains ah you have to be so painfully
specific about everything when you're
programming you know everything has to
be exactly so you know so you know
disregarding all the kind of skills you
need I think personality trait wise
there are you know the three p's that
are essential to be a good programmer is
you need to be patient you know the
computer is an absolute idiot you know
you need to be patient you need to be
persevering you can't just sit there
passively waiting for the computer to
figure it out you have to keep at it you
know and you have to be a bit of a
patent you know you have to really you
have to really really care about the
details because you know otherwise
you'll you'll go nuts because the
computer need that needs that and to put
it in a bit more you know positive spin
I mean I I grew up my I'm half American
so I grew up with this book so hopefully
enough of you recognize this but anyway
you have to be The Little Engine That
Could you know I think I can I think I
can I think I can you know when you're
stuck with this yaml config violence
that you know won't do what you wanted
to do it you're like okay I think I can
I think I can and you will manage in the
end you know you have to be an optimist
you have to be very persistent and
believe in yourself and you can do it
um but you know none of these things
that actually matter you know to create
good software none of these things
necessitate being this kind of science
genius I mean it doesn't hurt to be a
science genius you know learning science
and math they're wonderful you know that
doesn't make you you know you don't need
it but it's just it's not a requirement
and even these kinds of algorithmic you
know performance issues that we kind of
Imagine are you know that are essential
that you need to have this like
scientific mindset I think they aren't
uh they pop up anywhere you know they
pop up all over the place especially you
know the types of performance things
most of us actually have to deal with
you know just take things like um
managing managing work in a restaurant
kitchen you know and uh there any number
of examples I could uh could do
um but here like how do you organize the
work how do you organize the stuff you
know do you have like one Chef okay you
do the Carpaccio and you do the risotto
and you do the panna cotta or something
is that how you organize stuff for or do
you say well okay you do whatever table
three or you know orders do you group it
like that you know or and you're saying
okay you you do all the egg work you
know you you cut you know you break the
eggs you whisk the eggs you separate the
eggs you're the egg person uh okay a
frying pan you know anything that needs
frying you go to this guy oven heating
okay that's this guy
um now there are any number of ways of
course just as in programming there are
any number of ways that you can solve
any issue
but um it doesn't really it doesn't take
a kind of a tech genius to to realize
that maybe this is probably not the most
efficient one you know this is probably
not very efficient you know like none of
these guys are responsible for anything
that actually gives any value to anyone
you know there's going to be a lot of
unnecessary i o right there's going to
be a lot of you know communication
between the various parts you need
someone to organize you know how the
work between these guys were coordinated
um I mean this is probably not going to
be your best option again you don't need
to be this Tech genius to figure this
out
in fact though what seems to be true is
that the tech Geniuses are precisely the
people who find out that this is a good
idea because this all too often is just
what we end up with with like micro
Services architecture gone horribly
wrong where you have all these tiny
little things that don't do anything
that gives any value and they have to
communicate with every other service and
it's a total nightmare and no one can
debug anything or figure out why things
don't work you know it's us to do this
kind of thing you know and how many
people haven't seen you know you know
organization or software architecture
and organizations like this we have all
the front-end code is like here and you
have your front-end team and then you
have your back end team and then oh are
the rules in your application haha then
we need a rules engine or you know some
nonsense like that and then oh messaging
oh well here all the messaging is over
here you know this is our messaging team
and again none of these things have it
deliver anything that actually can you
know give value to anyone everything is
dependent on everything and then of
course you know ux the people who
actually get to meet the people who
actually have requirements you know
they're a totally separate team they get
to talk with the users and they make
pretty little drawings and everything's
nice and then they hand that over to the
tech team and we're like what the [__] I
can't even how would I even this is
impossible where you know but then it's
too late because they're off to the next
project you know and then you have to
you know since then you have your
testing organization that gets to check
if all of that chaos of coordination
actually delivers anything of value
this is the kind of stuff that we as
Tech Geniuses figure out all the time
huh this is not okay and the worst part
is like we don't even notice that we
have a problem because we're too excited
like oh we're using Nick's JS it's
amazing oh my God the rules engine takes
a hundred thousand requests per second
you know oh we're using Kafka yes
yes we don't notice that we're you know
totally messing up the whole thing
and you know it's understandable in a
way that we organize things this way you
know that we have our you know isolate
the various Tech levels on their own
because given uh that everything all
that you know all these new text
Technologies keep coming out
um being like full stack is practically
impossible you know everything every
year they're like five new Frameworks
that you need to learn for every layer
of this type of stuff huh it's
impossible to really have a good grasp
of every layer as it is today you know
just front end you know we've gone from
you know server-side rendering was
totally fine and then it's like Dr
surface
that's terrible we need now we've got
jQuery and then you know next five
minutes it's like a [__]
terrible we need to go to Backbone
is awful angular out on angular and I
react and I mean it just keeps going on
and I'm not saying there's nothing wrong
with any of these later things every
level here has improvements over that's
not the point I'm not trying to
criticize any of the individual
Technologies here I'm just saying we
really need to stop
you know this endless rewriting
everything because someone has a new
framework out there you know we are
causing the situation
that you know that you need to be able
to learn new things all the time yeah
this it doesn't have to be that way you
know and I know that you know
uh be you know the lots of uh like women
typically
don't feel comfortable and doing stuff
where they don't you know feel that they
know they are experts on what they're
doing right this is a well-known thing
that men are happy to jump into stuff I
don't know what I'm doing but it's okay
I'll manage you know and women typically
are a lot more they like actually
knowing what they're doing you know and
it's like in software it's like
shouldn't we be valuing knowing what
we're doing you know we we clearly we
would rather have people who don't know
what they're doing because it's
impossible to have a full grasp of all
this new stuff and we're encouraging
that you know and I don't know of any
other industry
that he gets away with this kind of
thing no one else it may be fashion
industry they change stuff all the time
but I mean any other serious industry
they would never get away with this
stuff you don't have like you know like
oh my God this drill is so old-fashioned
you know oh yeah yeah you know oh we
have to tear down your whole house you
know the Bosch just came out with a new
series of power tools I'm sorry your
house has to go and it's for your own
good because if we don't change out all
the screws in your house no one will
ever be able to work on your house ever
again because no one will want to use
those old tools you know
how are we getting away with this I mean
honestly we are spending you know we're
obviously making a fortune off this
right and we're having fun because we're
learning new things you know so we're
we're good right but I like how are we
getting away with it why are people
paying us so much money to behave like
this huh I you know someone has to catch
on soon and I'd like for us to be kind
of ahead of the curve so we can you know
anyway
um but yeah I mean like being trying to
you know there it's physically
impossible to to know all the new things
for all the stuff we are it's physically
impossible to actually be the kinds of
experts that we need to really you know
create good stuff that we know works
well huh I mean it's like 24 7. it's
more than a 24 7. I mean if you have
time to learn all of those things well
at depth knowing the details then you
don't have time for anything else
you know like
knowing what actually matters
yeah
what the software is for
again
this is what we're seeing
yeah we're so focused on the tick we're
so focused on the kind of you know
enjoying and for us for ourselves to
learn all these new stuff that we're
we're not focusing on what actually
matters
yeah
like are we actually any good at this
so I think we really need to rethink
what skills are needed
yeah our current perceptions
about programming or keeping people out
you know people are self-selecting out
of the recruitment pool you know they
they you know they can't even imagine
you know being important can you imagine
liking you know being really interested
and and uh communication or writing or
or you know just organizing stuff I know
a lot of people who are amazing at
organizing stuff and they love
organizing stuff yeah they wouldn't it
would never occur to them to even think
the programming could be something for
them
and this is a problem
I mean again people shouldn't be
thinking oh am I good at math I mean who
cares you know we should be asking these
things these are the things that we need
we should be asking ourselves
um
to you know whether or not you you would
be a good programmer you know again like
are you good at explaining things this
is like we can't even understand our own
code bases at the moment you know
this is not good
I mean imagine what our code bases would
look like
if the people who wrote software
were recruited not from the you know not
primarily because they were good at
maths or anything like that imagine what
our code bases would look like
if the people who wrote the software
primarily focused on clear communication
and like good organization skills huh
I think
our code bases would look a lot better
huh
and that and even like I can't even
remember a university I I can't even
remember uh learning about these things
reasoning about like how do we organize
how do we organize the data structures
before I started University I did um
programming at um at kind of high school
level and then we learned about database
modeling you know and there we talked
about like normalizing a data model and
stuff like what belongs where that's the
only time during my education anyway
where we actually focused on this kind
of thing
you know this is a serious problem
because this more than anything else at
every level of what we at every level of
our work this is what matters
being able to think about like you know
from from the top level architecture to
um to you know just uh one class or you
know a module or whatever your
programming language calls these things
you know which Fields belong in this
data structure and why how do we how do
we reason about our code bases how do we
reason about State how do we make our
code testable how do we you know these
kinds of things that's what matters
that's what we need to learn about and
that's what we should focus on you know
and again I'm not saying that these like
math skills that doesn't make you a bad
programmer I'm just saying it doesn't
make you a good programmer yeah and so
often you know you hear uh this you know
surprisingly convincing argument uh for
lots of people that uh oh women they
don't choose programming because they're
more their women are naturally more
interested in people than men
I'm like how is that relevant you know
like being interested in people doesn't
mean you're you can't be interested in
playing the guitar or or being good at
math or you know just like being
interested in math doesn't mean you
can't be good at communicating or
organizing things yeah it's possible
to have multiple interests
simultaneously right you know so I'm not
saying that you know we the people here
we are perfectly capable of course of
creating amazing software I'm just we
need to reconsider what it is that makes
our software great and it is the ability
to have good abstractions you know and
it's not about like you know just taking
that you know refactoring code example
and just every five lines of code you
extract a method and like yes now I've
organized my code you know it's not
about that yeah you need to be able to
think about how your code is actually
executing and what work is being done
how do these things you know what you
know who needs what responsibility and
all that kind of stuff and this is I
think the one thing where object
orientation beats functional programming
actually I'm I prefer functional
programming but you know object oriented
programming at least it makes it easier
to kind of think about these you know
things like like there's someone doing
some work you know so uh
um but anyway it's it's it's being able
to reason about how the code works
that's what matters you know we
desperately need
to spend less time just learning the
next new framework you know
so much time now we're like oh and and
every level you know oh we need to go to
the cloud and then then it's like oh
well actually on-prem is probably better
you know we're everything keeps going
back and forth you know we need to learn
we need to spend time just learning
about the basics of what makes our what
is important to us and what makes our
code actually work and if we get those
skills right you know it doesn't matter
then then well firstly it doesn't matter
what language or what Frameworks we use
because you can use anything to make a
decent solution mostly you know if you
know how to write code if you know how
to think about good abstractions then
you will be able to write a solution in
any language and more importantly you
will then be able to know that you know
what F sharp or closure or whatever
you'll know that these are better
languages and you'll know why they're
better languages and you will use those
better languages to write better code
because if you don't have that basic
skill set
you'll just make a complete mess of
whatever you're doing in that language
and then you'll say oh I tried F sharp
it's crap look at this horrible code you
know yeah or you know and this is you
know we really need to start figuring
out what actually matters
and finally you know we need more human
interest
you know we need to actually we need to
start you know caring about like you
know not just like does my component uh
have you know decent throughputs you
know can I handle you know five million
requests a minute or whatever you know
you this is matters you know but it
doesn't matter as much as looking at
well how how does this component that
I'm working on how does that actually
solve a human need we need to figure out
what are the what are the actual human
needs that we are helping serve and we
need to think about
um
how that how the whole ecosystem works
and to you know help organize our stuff
so that we are actually providing the
positive change that people actually
want to see in their lives and we need
to care about you know again we are a
very select little group you know we
again we like changes
our users might be old retired people
who you know didn't get got their first
computer when they were 65 they have
they hate it when things change yeah
they don't care if the UI looks like it
was designed in 2010 you know they you
know they would much rather have that
and then the buttons were in the same
place you know we need to actually
understand our users and provide things
that they actually need
because that's what matters
so that was all I had so thank you very
much and I hope you have a wonderful day
at NDC
[Applause]